a warning that our royal correspondent
rihanna mills's report contains flashing
images
they're two women who know every word
they say will be picked apart the
duchess of cornwall and carrie johnson
coming together to take a stand against
sexual violence
camilla using the opportunity to deliver
the most powerful speech of her royal
life
on average
one woman is killed by a man every three
days
sarah everard
sabina messer
wenjing lin
jatika goyal
and benellin burke are names which
with all the others
must never be forgotten
we do not in any way hold all men
responsible for sexual violence
but we do need them all aboard to tackle
it
after all rapists are not born they are
constructed
and it takes an entire community male
and female to dismantle the lies
words and actions that foster a cup
culture in which sexual assault is seen
as normal and in which it shames the
victim
camilla has talked about the issues of
rape and domestic violence for a number
of years now but what seems to have
changed is in the past there was maybe a
nervousness about what she said in
public now there's a clear determination
to do whatever she can to make a
difference
for the prime minister's wife it also
could not be more personal as a student
she was drugged by the taxi rapist john
warboys
the shameless festival against sexual
violence takes place in london next
month in camilla they have a powerful
advocate ready to reinforce the message
that enough is enough
rhiannon mills sky news in central
london